next question is from Trisha who says
what do you think about dog breed
discrimination or certain breeds such as
pitbulls more aggressive than others ok
I have strong feelings about this and
this is something I happen to know quite
a bit about I am completely against
breed specific legislation number one
which says that certain breeds of dog
are banned particularly because it's
very difficult to exactly identify many
breeds of dog and the pitbull paradox as
I call it is a great example of this and
there's this vicious cycle it's
currently pitbulls pitbulls are
currently like at the dangerous dog but
it used to be at one point German
Shepherds at one point it was
Rottweilers at one point it was
Dobermans there's different dogs that
over time have been the dangerous dog
and really what it comes down to is what
dog is in style typically for relatively
young men to have as a sort of badge of
the strong dog that will protect me type
of thing or the aggressive dog and with
pitbulls it's particularly probably Matt
problematic because first of all you
have ok people say hey look dog bites
overwhelmingly pitbulls and then you say
let's examine the data number one
pitbull is a type of dog there's a few
specific breeds like American Pit Bull
Terrier etc that are that are typically
what people talk about when they say
pitbull but most mixes or mutts that you
get at a shelter that at all resemble an
American Pit Bull Terrier will be
reported as pitbulls as dog bites you
this includes the Argentine Dogo this
includes some different Mastiffs this
includes the American Bulldog et cetera
so number one typically you're talking
about 15 to 20 different breeds of dogs
when you say look at the number of bites
from quote pitbulls
so that's deceptive to begin with but
further a lot of those bite lists are
made from media reports in other words
there's no central database of dog bites
so a lot of the lists are based on
reports of dog bites and there is self
selection bias
what's more likely to be a news story
that a pitbull bit someone or that a
cocker spaniel bit someone so I
completely reject the concept first of
all Pat that pitbulls are inherently
more dangerous
it is true is that when you look at the
particulars of the pit bulls that are
biting you have number one it's typical
it's overwhelmingly unneutered obviously
male dogs which is known to make all
breeds more aggressive you have very
often dogs that are kept chained outside
for long periods of time that are
engaged in these bites and number three
you have dogs that are owned by young
men who there's many young men who are
great dog owners but statistically
you're also looking at a group that may
be more likely to raise the dog in a
slightly different way so our pitbulls
inherently more aggressive
well pitbulls are not really bred to be
aggressive against humans if they are
that line is not supposed to be bred any
further there's no doubt that because of
the pitbull fighting rings that exist
there are individual pitbulls who have
probably been selectively bred for
aggressiveness but really it should be
aggressiveness against other dogs I
understand
dogs are traumatized that could come out
against people but by and large it is
all a sham and I'm completely against
breed specific legislation we really
just need to turn around our perception
of what's going on and realize that it's
the people that are the problem here
yeah I mean I'm honestly kind of
undecided on this i don't i don't agree
with breed specific legislation but just
in terms of how dangerous pitbulls are
because you can calculate the numbers
and see what dogs are more likely to
bite another person or another dog but i
think it's also the severity of how bad
those bites are and because pitbulls
were bred to not only bite but to latch
on through was a bull baiting when they
would add this sport in England and they
would actually like try to attack a bull
and and prevent them from moving any
further and so they were trained to hold
on and I think it becomes a bit of
nature versus nurture because even
though they were bred to do that and
participate in that sport I think
hundreds of years later you can see that
they are much more better in dealing
with humans yeah I mean I think what
you're saying it's partially true but
also plays into a lot of the pitbull
myths because there are many dog breeds
that have much stronger bites but while
it is German Shepherds I think about
time yeah yeah yeah so if it's a bite
strength argument alone that that's been
pretty widely debunked tell me I'm wrong
tell me I'm wrong if you actually look
at the data and the information that we
have about this and I'm just playing
devil's advocate I don't know either way
ya know I add those those would all be
good arguments if the data completely
backed it up but usually when you look
in it like the second layer of it you
find out that there's a grain of truth
but it's been distorted and sort of
blown out of proportion